have you ever wondered how it's possible
to scratch a CD or a DVD and still have
it play back whatever it's storing the
scratch really does affect the ones and
zeros on the disk so it reads off
different data from what was stored but
unless it's really scratched up the bits
that it reads off are decoded into
precisely the same file that was encoded
onto it any file whether it's a video or
sound or text uh some code and image
whatever is ultimately some sequence of
ones and zeros and a simple strategy to
correct any bit that gets flipped would
be to store three copies of each bit but
what that means is using 2/3 of your
space for redundancy the much more
interesting question is how to make it
so that errors can be corrected while
giving up as little space as possible
for example using the method that you'll
learn about this video you could store
your data in 256-bit blocks where each
block uses nine bits nine to act as a
kind of redundancy and the other